get right out to chief meteorologist ted  florendo located  at the smiths on north rampart for our  continuing coverage of our great school  supply drive  hey good evening to you brian yeah this  has been going on since june 17th but  today  is our final day of the great school  supply drive  benefiting shade tree and the kids of  clark county now keep in mind  we know that is virtual learning this  year at least the first part of the year  but kids remember at home still need  those school supplies  even if they're at home so keep that in  mind and we need your help  too to help make that happen okay we  want to take a look at the four